[Musica]
dubbi in origine era il caos
poi venne gaia la dea terra e tartaro il
dio tenebroso e sotterraneo e infine
eros il più bello tra di dei mortali
l'unico in grado di sottomettere il
cuore e il saggio consiglio quindi per
esiodo eros è figlio del caos nato
direttamente da lui anzi partorito
direttamente da lui e rappresenta uno
dei primi quattro elementi primordiali
eros quindi non è un sentimento ma è un
incontrollabile forza generativa a cui
lei e uomini devono sottostare e
l'impulso verso la vita uno slancio
verso la riproduzione per la mitologia
classica invece eros è figlio di
afrodite dea della bellezza e ares il
dio della guerra tra questi due dei
esisteva una violentissima passione
corporea eros viene rappresentato come
un bambino a lato spesso bendato
irrazionale e dispettoso e rosso si
manifesta con una potentissima
attrazione con il tormento con la follia
della gelosia ma è anche un intenso
legame
ciò che rende uomini e dei fedeli e
devoti comunque quale che sia la sua
origine
eros tende sempre verso il caos
l'eros ha bisogno del caos per
rinnovarsi si alimenta del caos e lo fa
attaccando i legali suscitando gelosia
creando attrazione tanto che afrodite
disperata per le imprese di suo figlio
decide di generare anteros l'amore
corrisposto dal momento in cui nacque
anteros tornò alla pace perché quando i
due fratelli st
insieme d'amore era appunto corrisposto
ma nel momento in cui anteros si è
allontanato dal fratello eros tornava ad
essere il bambino dispettoso e andava in
giro scagliando le sue frecce seminando
il terrore tra uomini e dei figli del
caos e anche la notte da cui nasce
discordia e biasimo discordia è una dea
crudele è la madre del dolore suscitava
di tg e scatenava guerre ma era anche
una dea importante in quanto era in
grado di attivare la competizione degli
uomini e quindi di liberarli dalla loro
innata pigrizia senza la discordia gli
uomini sarebbero rimasti per sempre
immobili quindi se eros rappresenta la
forza del desiderio il potere del
desiderio discordia rappresenta il
desiderio di potere
tutte le volte che noi lasciamo spazio
alla competizione al desiderio di
sopraffare l'altro tutte le volte che
facciamo venire prima i nostri desideri
in specchia rispetto a quelli dell'altro
vuol dire che eros sta lasciando il
posto a discordia ma la discordia è
necessaria l'eros proprio perché eros ha
bisogno del caos nei rapporti dove non
c'è conflitto dove non c'è competizione
prima o poi
l'eros sparisce quindi come possiamo
fare per tenere insieme questi bei
all'interno della coppia e fare in modo
che la coppia cresca mantenendo l'eros
possiamo imparare cinque lezioni tra da
eros e discordia la prima è accettare la
diversità uomini e donne sono diversi
siamo tutti diversi abbiamo tutti i
bisogni diversi
lo sappiamo ma attendiamo a
dimenticarselo
o almeno non ci crediamo fino in fondo
soprattutto quando litighiamo ma quali
sono le differenze innanzitutto esistono
delle differenze anatomiche alcune
visibili il corpo degli uomini è diverso
dal corpo delle donne
ma esistono anche delle differenze
proprio nel cervello tanto per fare un
esempio i due emisferi della donna
comunicano tra di loro molto di più
rispetto agli uomini
e questo le donne lo sanno mentre invece
gli uomini comunicano di più all'interno
dello stesso emisfero questo genera
moltissime differenze sia da un punto di
vista di percezione che di comportamento
esistono poi delle enormi differenze a
livello culturale nel senso che secoli
di tradizioni non si cancellano in pochi
attimi quindi come la maggior parte
delle mamme sa per noi donne non è un
problema accompagnare il figlio
all'interno dello spogliatoio maschile
per cambiarlo soprattutto quando è
piccolo
cosa che invece non farebbe mai un uomo
perché per un uomo è inconcepibile
entrare all'interno di uno spogliatoio
di danza per cambiare la figlia femmina
in modo analogo se non stiamo al
ristorante il bagno degli uomini
occupato non ci facciamo grossi problemi
a usare e scusate quello delle donne
a usare quello degli uomini
cosa che invece non verrebbe mai inventa
un uomo immaginate cosa accadrebbe se le
signore vedessero uscire un uomo dal
bagno delle donne quindi insomma siamo
molto diversi esistono tantissime
differenze anche proprio nel modo di
porci le donne sono più empatiche
tendono a perdonare più facilmente gli
uomini faticano a scusarsi
anche quando sbagliano ma risultano più
collaborativi soprattutto nel lavoro
quando ci sono delle differenze
gerarchiche dove invece le donne
manifestano più difficoltà le donne
appaiono più sensibili e attenti nelle
relazioni ma faticano a tollerare le
frustrazioni e sono più apprensive
pensate al momento in cui dobbiamo
decidere se acquistare il motorino del
figlio insomma siamo diversi e fino a
quando non accetteremo questa
indiscutibile verità
i rapporti tra uomini e donne saranno
sempre complicati
la seconda lezione che possiamo imparare
è andare verso l'altro
quindi se sappiamo che siamo diversi
abbiamo un modo di reagire diverso tra
uomini e donne gli uomini generalmente
accettano di non capire la donna o
almeno così fanno credere
le donne invece no le donne non riescono
ad accettare quello che non capiscono
hanno bisogno di una spiegazione hanno
bisogno di un perché
e attenzione non sono luoghi comuni
perché in tantissimi anni di professione
e dai numerosissimi messaggi che io
ricevo ogni giorno
raramente un uomo mi ha chiesto di
spiegargli il comportamento della sua
compagna mentre spesso le donne mi
chiedono di dare una spiegazione al
perché il loro uomo si comporta in un
certo modo ma su che cosa mi richiedono
una consulenza gli uomini le donne
per quanto riguarda la sfera affettiva
gli uomini generalmente vengono da me
perché sono sfiniti da litigi e vogliono
mettere fine al conflitto
oppure vogliono essere accompagnati in
una separazione perché non riescono a
decidersi o magari desiderano fare
chiarezza sui loro sentimenti
sapete su che cosa mi chiedono una
consulenza le donne vogliono sapere
perché gli uomini hanno paura delle
relazioni dando per scontato che gli
uomini abbiano paura
vogliono sapere perché spariscono dopo
aver passato una bella serata
vogliono capire perché continuano a
cercarli anche se non vogliono una
relazione e soprattutto vogliono sapere
come fare per cambiarle
insomma le donne stanno sempre nella
mente dell'altro le donne stanno in
relazione anche quando soffrono ma
attenzione il fatto che le donne
cerchino di capire di più il
comportamento maschile non vuol dire che
realmente li comprendano di più gli
uomini perché purtroppo tendono a
interpretare il comportamento maschile
sulla base di come sono fatte loro
insomma il punto è che noi fatichiamo
tantissimo ad andare oltre
gli schemi mentali volete una prova
pensate alla convinzione una cosa che
veramente vi da fastidio di voi stessi
che vi fa soffrire
qualcosa del tipo che ne so sono brutto
nessuno mia ma devo fare sempre tutto da
solo non posso chiedere aiuto non ha una
buona madre qualcosa che vi turba
nonostante moltissime persone amici
parenti e sconosciuti colleghi vi
abbiano sicuramente detto che questa
cosa non è vera
voi continuate a crederci continuate a
mantenerla nella vostra
continuate a mantenere questa vostra
convinzione
quindi se non riusciamo a cambiare le
nostre convinzioni anche quando
cambiarle ci aiuterebbe possiamo
cambiare le condizioni le convinzioni
soltanto per andare incontro all'altro
generalmente no è davvero molto
difficile e se state pensando che siamo
tutti auto centrati è vero ma non vi
preoccupate perché si può cambiare e poi
siamo tutti un po egoisti ed egocentrici
la terza cosa che possiamo imparare
dalle relazioni in particolare dai
conflitti nelle relazioni e conoscere
meglio noi stessi
young e diceva che tutto ciò che ci
ritagli gli altri può portarci alla
maggiore conoscenza di noi stessi
esiste infatti un meccanismo difensivo
che si chiama proiezione che ci fa
tendere ad attribuire all'altro cose che
non ci piacciono di noi quindi gli
aspetti di noi poco tollerati tendiamo
ad attribuirli all'altro e quindi nel
vedere un comportamento lo stesso che
abbiamo noi ma che non ci piace
nell'altro proviamo una grande rabbia ma
come facciamo a capire se si tratta di
una proiezione fosse davvero quel
comportamento ci dà fastidio
dall'intensità della reazione se la
reazione che noi abbiamo è spropositata
rispetto a ciò che sta accadendo è molto
facile che si tratta di una proiezione
insomma
diciamo che nel momento in cui stiamo
all'interno della coppia abbiamo milioni
di occasioni per conoscere meglio noi
stessi e anche quando litighiamo
vi faccio un esempio noi crediamo di
litigare per questi motivi sesso figli
tempo libero e soldi e lavoro
questi sono i motivi per cui
generalmente si litiga all'interno di
una coppia ma raramente sono i motivi
reali per cui litighiamo il motivo per
cui litighiamo invece generalmente è
molto più personale e si tratta di
mancanza d'amore quindi prendiamo un
pretesto qualunque ma semplicemente non
ci amiamo più non siamo soddisfatti del
sesso e quindi la frustrazione la
spostiamo da un'altra parte
abbiamo differenze di valori abbiamo un
bisogno di controllo quindi di entrare
nella mente nella vita dell'altro
proviamo nvidia rancori oppure mettiamo
in atto dei giochi di potere oppure
importantissimo cerchiamo di risolvere
all'interno della coppia e problemi
personali
quindi cerchiamo la soddisfazione di
bisogni insoddisfatti di placare le
nostre insicurezze le nostre paure
insomma quello che voglio dire è che
spesso il motivo per cui discutiamo è
molto distante dal motivo reale
facciamo un esempio pratico se tu esci
con gli amici e io interpreto questo tuo
comportamento come tu esci con gli amici
questo significa che preferisci il loro
a me e quindi vuol dire che io non sono
parti non sono abbastanza importante per
te il problema non è più quello che tu
stai facendo
ma è significato che io sto dando al tuo
comportamento e l'errata interpretazione
è spesso alla base dei conflitti più
importanti perché non arriveremo mai a
un accordo visto che il motivo per cui
stiamo litigando non è quello reale
qualche giorno fa ho fatto un test sui
social un sondaggio e ho scritto
preferire essi di più essere amata o
essere desiderata la maggior parte delle
donne
ha scritto desiderata
così almeno non mi tradisce quindi
dietro a quella che apparentemente si
presenta come una scelta di fatto c'è il
tentativo di contenere una paura
profonda in questo caso quella di essere
tradite
ho fatto il test anche per gli uomini ma
nonostante io abbia scritto gigantesco
solo per uomini
l'ottanta per cento delle risposte è
stata data da donne siamo fatti così
insomma la confusione tra il
comportamento cioè quello che tu fai e
il significato che io attribuisco al tuo
comportamento è la causa numero uno dei
conflitti quindi il vero motivo per cui
noi litighiamo è la dietrologia che
facciamo
la quarta cosa che possiamo imparare dai
conflitti di coppia è ridimensionare le
nostre aspettative
gli uomini le donne hanno aspettative
realistiche sia per quanto riguarda la
relazione che per quanto riguarda le
persone ma anche per quanto riguarda la
vita noi progettiamo la nostra vita la
immaginiamo nei minimi dettagli ci
facciamo il film e poi ci aspettiamo che
le cose vadano esattamente in quel modo
e se non accade noi rimaniamo delusi noi
crediamo veramente che le cose
dovrebbero andare in un certo modo per
il semplice fatto che noi le abbiamo
immaginate o desiderate la stessa cosa
accade con le persone
noi decidiamo entro i primi quattro
minuti se una persona ci attrae oppure
no attenzione parlo di attrazione non di
amore
eppure dopo 4 minuti noi cominciamo a
fantasticare su quella persona
cominciamo a immaginare come potrebbe o
dovrebbe essere
e se poi non è così che cosa succede che
rimaniamo delusi deluse ma da che cosa
che colpa all'altro se non è esattamente
uguale al modello che io avevo in mente
oppure accade che coincidenza è
esattamente come lo volevo e ci
aspettiamo che rimanga
così per sempre indipendentemente dal
tempo che passa e indipendentemente
dalle vicissitudini di coppia
ora le persone cambiano nel tempo e
ahimé cambiano anche i sentimenti
inoltre noi siamo così presi dal
concentrarci sulle mancanze dell'altro
che noi non vediamo quello che facciamo
noi per causare quel cambiamento
molte donne vengono nel mio studio e si
lamentano del fatto che magari il
partner non è più così affettuoso come
lo era all'inizio e poi passano tutta
l'ora a criticarlo
allora come posso essere affettuoso con
te se tu passi tutto il giorno a vedere
soltanto le cose che non vanno bene
oppure uomini che si lamentano perché la
loro compagna non ha più voglia di fare
sesso e poi si scopre che si avvicina a
lei soltanto la sera in cui vuole fare
l'amore
insomma quello che voglio dire è che noi
la vita la dobbiamo vivere per come e
non per come vorremmo che fosse e che le
persone dovrebbero essere amate e non
per come per come sono e non per come le
immaginiamo la quinta cosa che possiamo
imparare dalle relazioni e cercare la
felicità nel luogo giusto
noi cerchiamo la felicità generalmente
al di fuori di noi
noi crediamo davvero che le persone
dovrebbero prodigarsi per renderci
felici e crediamo che la vita in qualche
modo ci debba un premio o un
risarcimento per la nostra fatica di
esistere la verità è che nessuno ci deve
nulla è ciò che dovremmo imparare è che
la vita è fatta in egual misura di gioia
e sofferenza mentre noi intraprendiamo
estenuanti battaglie nel tentativo di
eliminare il dolore dalle nostre vite
non solo nel momento in cui realmente
siamo felici non riusciamo a goderselo e
perché abbiamo paura che finiscano
inoltre la sopravvalutazione dell'amore
romantico ci porta a credere che noi
possiamo trovare la nostra felicità
all'interno della coppia e che quello
sia
sufficiente quindi rinunciano agli amici
agli hobby alle passioni e soprattutto
alla nostra auto realizzazione per
quanto bella possa essere la storia che
noi abbiamo creato e per quanto
straordinaria possa essere la persona
che abbiamo accanto non sarà mai
abbastanza ed è giusto che sia così
perché il partner non può sostituire il
mondo intero e soprattutto non può
aiutarci in quel compito straordinario
che è la realizzazione della nostra vita
noi dovremmo trovare il nostro posto
dovremmo capire perché siamo qui ed ora
e questo nessuno può aiutarci a farlo se
no noi stessi magari accanto a un altro
ma dovremo farlo da soli
comunque non importa che tu sia un uomo
una donna un dio in realtà dovremmo
trovarci davanti a una scelta e decidere
serenamente consapevolmente se far
entrare il caos nelle nostre vite e
inseme al caos eros e disordine oppure
se scegliere l'ordine e rinunciare per
sempre alle nostre passioni
grazie